I think the way that you've been seeing
technology transform education is that
were able to utilize people in a way now
that's bringing the outside world into
the classroom that maybe before it was a
person had to physically go there and do
something and you know they only had the
capacity to do that once now we're able
to stream people in and and bring them
out petition in and we're looking at
behavior change technology allows us to
have that repetition that's necessary
for behavior change so I think that's to
me that's the the biggest thing that we
believe classroom champions is that
technology is enabling us to cause
behavior change by bringing repetition
into the mix costume champions is in
essence the flipped model of what we've
been doing for eons
whether it be an athlete or whether it
be a prominent person who's gone in to
talk to youth we've been doing that
forever well at the end of the day as an
athlete I would always walk out of a
school I go you know what if one or two
kids listened it was worth my time and
when we put classroom champions together
and I say we my sister and I my sister's
got her PhD in education and Social
Policy from Northwestern we we wanted to
do something would be more impactful
than that one-off visit where you walk
in you give a talk to kids it's fun it's
engaging then you leave and you never
see people again and classrooms that
means we've taken that model and flipped
it using technology where we have
Olympians and Paralympians across right
now the US Canada and Costa Rica and
these athletes every month they're able
to focus on a different video lesson and
send these to the classrooms that we
adopt for them and they actually form
personal relationships with these kids
because the kids are able to send videos
back so when they do that they're
actually sending it to somebody who is
somebody an Olympian the power of that
is something that we're seeing where
we're seeing kids that are now happy to
to set goals and engage and persevere
better because they're understanding it
because they're their mentors are
teaching them those lessons and at
classroom champions we believe that
repetition causes behavior change and
that's what we see with through the
technology through the the pre-recorded
video lessons every month that the
athletes send in you know just a few
weeks before each month they record
these videos and then the kids are
actually able to a couple times a year
whether it be Skype or Google hangout
these athletes are then able to answer
the kids questions
and when you make that connection real
you actually put an extra mint or an
extra role model in these kids lives and
all kinds of things wonderful happen at
that point